So during my interview on yesterday's show
with Coleman Hughes, this topic of fixing
policing came up and we talked about a couple
of different ideas related to that.
And one of the things that I had mentioned
was focusing in a little bit on traffic enforcement
as a sort of proxy to fighting a lot of what's
wrong with policing in the United States.
And I got a bunch of e-mails about it from
people saying, how would that movie that look
like?
Can you talk about that a little more?
So let's let's do that today.
Now, as a pretext to this, I don't have any
misconception that dealing with traffic laws
is the solution to every problem with policing
in the United States.
It's not for dealing with traffic.
Enforcement wouldn't do anything about lack
of training or improper training or the wrong
training.
It wouldn't address qualified immunity.
If that's something we want to look at, it
wouldn't, you know, deal with funding or a
whole bunch of other things.
But there's a reason why traffic enforcement
is arguably some of the lowest hanging fruit
that we should look at right away when it
comes to policing, which is that traffic enforcement
is, number one, an area where police are allowed
a lot of discretion and inherent bias manifests
when there is discretion.
And number two, traffic enforcement and traffic
related infractions are the primary way in
which Americans interact with police.
By number of incidents every single year.
And so what what I mean by this is when it
comes to traffic enforcement, we're all familiar
with situations in which I get pulled over
and you get pulled over and are told we were
driving 12 miles an hour over the speed limit.
In other words, the pretext for the stop is
exactly the same, but there might be very
different outcomes based on the discretion
of the officer.
So I might end up with a speeding ticket and
points on my insurance paying a higher insurance
rate for several years.
I might get my car searched because the officer
believes that they smell alcohol in my car
when they pull me over.
Meanwhile, you might get pulled over doing
the same alleged 12 miles an hour over the
speed limit.
And you get a verbal warning.
And I have a nice day.
And the repercussions of the discretion that
is applied by officers to the same scenario
can be dramatically different, even when the
facts are essentially the same.
And this could be just a result of the bias
of the police officer.
Officers have a lot of discretion in terms
of who they pull over when they see somebody
run a stop sign, for example, once they pull
them over, who do they question more aggressively?
Whose vehicles are they more interested in
searching?
Who do they have step out of the vehicle for
a field sobriety test when a car drives by
with a tail light out.
That discretion can be the difference between
an interaction that leads to a police shooting
or ultimately an arrest versus someone who
just drives home, not even realizing that
they drove by a police officer with their
tail light and taillight out.
So because traffic enforcement is the most
common way that people come into contact with
police every year, year in and year out.
And it can serve as a sort of blank slate
from which investigations can start.
We should be looking at this very closely.
So what are some ways to reduce the discretion
which can be influenced by bias when it comes
to traffic enforcement?
One idea is to replace some traffic enforcement
with automation whenever possible.
By that, we mostly mean cameras because of
course, that is a way to eliminate a bias
from an individual officer now.
You can still choose to put the cameras in
certain neighborhoods and not in others.
And you may have people who are of a certain
economic class who can better lobby to prevent
the cameras from coming into their neighborhoods
and push the cameras into poor neighborhoods
or black neighborhoods or whatever the case
may be.
But it's something to look at.
You can have situations, you know, on highways.
It's typical that on highways, people everybody's
driving over the speed limit.
Then you need to figure out if you're going
to replace highway speed traps with cameras.
Well, how much speeding is acceptable?
There's some complexities there, but at least
in some cases, automating elements of traffic
enforcement would dramatically reduce interactions
with police.
And it would therefore reduce the number of
interactions that become problematic.
Replacing traffic enforcement and speed traps
with police cameras would limit the bias of
an officer in leading to discretion being
used in a discriminatory way, for example.
Now, it's not a replacement for fixing all
of the other things that are broken, certainly,
but it would be significant nonetheless.
So then there's the idea of having someone
other than armed police handle some traffic
enforcement.
We've talked about homelessness, mental illness.
Do we really need arm?
Police handling calls to nine one one related
to homelessness.
It's probably better suited to some other
kind of professional.
If we can't have better trained officers trained
like social workers, for example.
Maybe there would be some other type of professional
that would be better suited here.
Something analogous could be, you know, for
certain types of traffic infractions.
You would have something other than an armed
police officer.
Now, the devil is in the details, of course.
And it's true that while the vast majority
of traffic infractions don't escalate in any
way, and the ones that do sometimes escalate
because of the officer, there can be traffic
infractions where someone knows that they
have a warrant and it can lead to erratic
behavior.
There's a lot of guns floating around there.
So you've got you've got to think it through
right there.
This is not an obvious and easy solution,
but it's something to look at.
But the point is, and this is why I feel strongly
about it, when 20 million motorists per year
are pulled over, according to the Stanford
Policing Project, and these interactions,
traffic related interactions opened the door
to such a huge amount of discretion on the
part of the officer.
It's an area of low hanging fruit.
We're finding some aspects to automate, finding
other areas better suited for a different
type of professional than an armed police
officer.
We could make a lot of progress there.
While I don't want to ignore this, while we
look at dealing with training, qualified immunity,
lack of a bad actors database at the federal
level, all of the different things that we've
been talking about, let me know your thoughts.
Does this seem like an avenue that should
be pursued?
What do you see as the obstacles?
What do you see as the possible.
Shortcomings of it.
That maybe I'm ignoring.
Let me know what you think.